ADE OSHINEYE: OK.
I think we're ready to start.
Are you ready to start?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ADE OSHINEYE: Good.
I was just worried that somebody
would say no, and it
would be awkward.
AUDIENCE: No.
ADE OSHINEYE: Excellent.
So I'm Ade Oshineye.
I'm going to be your
developer advocate
for the next 45 minutes.
And we're going to be talking
about Google+ Sign-In for web
applications.
I'm going to be trying to make
this interesting for those of
you who have already
used our APIs.
I'm going to be trying to show
you how you can make this
valuable, how you can make
Sign-In a valuable addition to
what you're building.
If you've been to any talks by
me before, you'll know that I
like questions during it.
However, because this is being
recorded, I'd like you to
defer questions until the end.
And please use the microphones
so that it shows up for the
recordings.
Thank you.
So let's talk about
Google+ Sign-In,
specifically Web Sign-In.
But let's start with
something else.
Who here prefers knives
to forks?
OK, who prefers forks
to knives?
Wow.
There are a lot of people
who like forks here.
So who prefers the web
to native apps?
What about native
apps to the web?
It's a little more even here.
The thing I'm trying to convey
is that just like with knives
and forks, we need the
web and native apps.
They work best together.
And what we're trying to do with
the Sign-In features is
based on this sort
of thinking.
Despite the fact that we need
all of this stuff, we're
Google, and we believe
firmly that it all
starts with the web.
So even though users switch all
the time, dozens of times
a day, between multiple
different devices and will
continue the same user journey
across multiple devices, it
still starts with the web.
The web is where people discover
your site, your app,
the thing you're building.
The other thing we believe is
that when it comes to building
a social web app, social is not
something you sprinkle on
afterwards.
It's not something you hack
into an existing thing.
It's not just I put a
button there-- done.
You've got to rethink how you're
building your site.
You've got to redesign it.
You've got to think about
how you make this
valuable for users.
Now, who was here at
last year's I/O?
Excellent.
So you may have seen
this slide.
It's OK.
It can't hurt you.
So in the past, we've talked
a lot about the technology
behind social, about identity.
We've talked a lot
about OAuth.
Who here has fond memories
of OAuth?
Nobody.
OK.
Who here found OAuth painful?
Who here found OAuth was
something that required you to
be a rocket scientist to
get stuff to work?
So we're trying to fix that.
We're trying to move to a
world where things are
simpler, where you don't need
a lab coat to do social.
We've built a whole suite of
client libraries and SDKs
across all of the major
languages, the major
platforms, so that Sign-In
and other social
features are very easy.
We've built quickstarts designed
to get you up and
running within 15 minutes so
that you can build a very
simple web app, add Sign-In,
understand what's possible,
then go to your own real
application and think about
what's going to be best for your
users in that context.
The Google+ platform has matured
greatly since I was on
this stage last year.
We have a much wider range of
features and a much wider
range of platforms.
We have a platform that's aware
of the multi-device,
multi-platform reality
we all live in today.
And I'm going to show you some
examples, some of which are
going to come from applications
that are being
built by partners who are out
there, and some of which are
going to come from this app.
It's an instance of the
demonstration application
called PhotoHunt
that we built.
I shipped this publicly about
seven days ago, and it's had
huge numbers of users.
So let's start with how Sign-In
works and why Sign-In.
So at Google, we believe it's
really important that the user
gets one secure method of
signing into our services so
that the user is strongly
encouraged to do things like
use two-factor authentication.
The thing is, two-factor
authentication is the right
thing for users' [INAUDIBLE]
security.
But once they sign in once, if
every site they go to requires
them to sign in, and then every
site has to also have
two-factor authentication, life
is really, really hard.
So we're trying to say, can we
make this something that other
people can piggyback on,
can take advantage of?
So how do you do this?
How do you actually take
advantage of Google+ Sign-In?
How do you start?
Well, with everything we're
doing, it starts
with the API Console.
Who here has not seen
the Console?
OK, we have a few.
That's OK.
So you can go to
developers.google.com/console.
It will redirect you to the
more complicated URL.
The very first thing you do
is you create a project.
That's easy enough.
You choose which of the dozens
of Google APIs you
are going to enable.
I'm biased, so I recommend
Google+ as the first place.
So that having done that--
as you can see, mine's called
Ade's Photohunt.
You then just choose
your team.
Now, if you're building an
application, there's usually
more than just you
working on it.
There are other people who
need access to things.
If you're building a large web
application, you may have a
large team.
You may have iOS developers,
Android developers, as well as
you building the web stuff.
So the API Console provides
you the tools to do this.
And then you populate
the client IDs.
One of the things people often
miss about the way the API
Console works is you have
the project, which
has a project number.
Then there are multiple
client IDs.
So your iOS app may
have a client ID.
Your Android app may
Your web app may have
a client ID.
But they're all connected to
that project, which means when
later on we talk about some of
the OAuth token stuff, we know
they are all with the
same project.
So revocation on one
revokes on all.
If you've seen some of the talks
by people like Seth and
David Glazer, where they've
been talking about
Cross-device Single Sign-On and
the notion that the user
authenticates the service, not
the app, a lot of that is
based on the fact that we have
client IDs for each of the
different apps.
But we know they're all attached
to the project.
And effectively, the project
is the service.
So create a client ID.
You can see the [INAUDIBLE]
my demo account.
And you can see I'm too lazy
to put any graphics in.
And then there's some
OAuth stuff.
So in this case, I'm
going to be using
the JavaScript button.
So I only need to specify
the JavaScript origins.
So this is the sites the button
is going to be on.
Because we're going through
the API Console, and we're
trying to set everything up,
we take a look at the API
traffic report.
As you can see, my demo app has
been massively successful.
But this is where you'd see
the amount of traffic your
site will send into Google.
And if you've got massive,
massive amounts of traffic,
you would basically be able to
go here and be able to request
more quota.
Or if it's an API that requires
billing, this is
where this would happen.
As you can see, my app has
not had that problem.
So one of the first questions
you should ask before you
start implementing
Sign-In is, why?
Why is this going to be
valuable to the user?
If you just put a Sign-In button
there, but then after
the user signs in nothing
has changed, then it
wasn't worth it.
What makes this valuable is that
the user signs in, and
they get something new,
something different.
So for example, you may
store preferences.
Or you may let them discover
other people they know who are
using this, who are using
your service.
Implementing it is very easy.
So that's what our standard
Google+ Sign in
button looks like.
We've moved very much to a model
where we say for most
people most of the time, they
just want to turn up, cut and
paste the buttons in, and then
get back to thinking about
their web app and not about
our infrastructure or our
technologies or OAuth or OpenID
or OpenID Connect or
any of that menagerie of
standards and technologies.
So you cut and paste
the JavaScript.
This is going to asynchronously
insert.
The JavaScript is going to
load our JavaScript file.
You put in the button, because
you've got to have the actual
markup for the button.
You don't have to
use our button.
We do have features that let
you do custom rendering.
And many of our partners have
gone for subtle variations on
our brand that fits in better
with their sites.
But for most people, you
simply say, that's
the button I want.
g-signin is the class.
Our JavaScript will later
on rewrite that page.
You say the scopes you want.
So that's a space-separated
list of the scopes.
You say you want to request
visible actions.
We'll talk about this later,
but this is what gives you
access to app activities.
You put your client ID in.
Now, I said client ID.
It's important you put
your client ID,
not your client secret.
Obviously, nobody here
would ever do that.
And a call back, which we'll
talk about later.
You can put in a theme.
And you can do some interesting
stuff with cookie
policy, which affects
how we cache the
JavaScript that's loaded.
In your callback, after the user
clicks the button, goes
through our consent flow--
I assume-- has everybody here
signed in to Google+ at least
once somewhere?
OK, good.
So after the Sign-In flow, your
JavaScript is going to
get called.
And then in that, you say, OK,
the user just signed in.
I have an access token
for that user.
I can make calls to Google's
APIs on behalf of that user.
Now, this is the point where you
show the user some value.
So this is a basic safe thing.
You should reflect the user's
identity back at them.
So who did I just sign in as?
Show me the photo.
Show me the name.
If I've got multiple log-in,
if I'm signing in multiple
accounts, this is the step where
you confirm that I've
actually signed in with my
proper account and not my
corporate account or somebody
else's account
who's using my machine.
In one of our quickstarts, in
this case the JavaScript quick
start, we show you how you can
do Sign-In in PhotoHunt.
That's how we reflect a user's
identity back at them.
We show the name, and
we show the photo.
Because these are my profiles,
I know that photo means it's
my demo account.
So I know, OK, that's fine.
And we also offer disconnect.
One of the things that's really
important with Sign-In
is the user can sign in and sign
out of your service, but
it can also connect and
disconnect to your service
from Google.
And it's important you offer
the user the ability to
disconnect your service
from Google.
And when they do that, it's
important you delete the data
they've given you through
the Google+ API.
You can keep things like
the profile ID
and the email address.
But for everything else, the
user says they don't want to
have anything to do with
you anymore, you have
to give up the data.
So disconnect is very easy.
You simply call the revoke
endpoint, passing in the OAuth
token you had in your
JavaScript.
And then you do whatever's
necessary to make sure the
user's data is no longer
being stored by you.
So client side is largely a
matter of cutting and pasting
code from our documentation.
And then you have a JavaScript
client that has an access
token and can make calls to a
wide range of Google APIs on
behalf of the current user.
Now, this access token is going
to expire in 60 minutes.
But you've decided to do
this for a reason.
If you want a longer engagement
with the user, if
you want perhaps to save the
tokens so they can do more
things in the future,
you make a couple of
relatively small changes.
You use what we've called at
various times the set aside
flow, the hybrid flow, and
the one-time-code flow.
Basically, what this does is
the user signs in with the
client-side button.
Get Access token is going to
be used by the client side.
We don't want you passing
access tokens
over insecure channels.
If you've looked at the OAuth
specs, you'll know that the
tokens you have are
bearer tokens.
Anybody who has that token
can act as you.
So what we recommend instead
is you get a code from us.
So you have a transient code.
You pass that to your server.
The interesting thing about the
code is it's only going to
work for anybody who has your
client secret, which means
they're you, basically.
So your server then has a code,
calls Google over a
secure channel.
We can ensure it's a secure
channel because we
own one end of it.
And then after this, we say,
yes, we know it's you.
We've verified it's you.
Here's an Access token
and Refresh token,
which you then store.
And now you can make offline
calls on behalf of the user.
So switching to this mode,
because it's pretty much of
adding these two lines
to your button.
So again, we've tried to go with
something that's very,
very simple.
You obviously have to do some
checks of things like
cross-site request forgery.
But it's still relatively
easy.
So the user's signed
up to your service.
They've connected your
service to Google.
How do you connect--
how do you customize
this service?
Well, you think about
what's going on.
The user's turned up.
They've brought their profile.
This is my profile,
my demo one.
My demo one isn't especially
popular.
You can do a bunch of
things now with the
access you've got.
So even if all you've asked for
is access to their Google+
account, you still have
access to things
like the user's profile.
So you can look at
that and extract,
perhaps, their interests.
So this almost unreadable screen
shot is what it looks
like when my demo account or
any public user looks at my
actual profile.
There's a lot of data there
about my interests, places
I've worked, sites I
have accounts to
that I've linked to.
So what you can do is you can
look at this, and you can do
very simple things like term
extraction, entity detection,
and go, I now know what
this user cares about.
And this is all public data.
So this is data the user felt
comfortable sharing with you
or with anybody else.
You can do other things.
For example, you could look at
the social graph of the people
on your site.
And when the user signed in,
they gave you access to a
subset of their social graph,
and you can map them.
And you can tell the user,
here are several of your
friends who are already
on the site.
So if you try a service like
SoundCloud, for instance,
that's what they do.
There are people you already
know who are here.
Again, this is all public data,
or you've chosen to give
them that subset of
your social graph
so they can do this.
The other thing that's really
important is that when the
user signs in, that initial
out of the box experience
should be magical.
It should show them that it
was worth signing in.
If I sign in and nothing
changes,
well, why did I bother?
The other thing that's really
important is that when people
get to your site, and they think
it's cool, they think
it's good, they want to
tell other people.
Historically, the way that
happened was they
would share a link.
So this is NPR, that
their fancy.
And they would share a link.
And implicitly, they'd
be saying to
people, here's a link.
It's cool.
That's it.
There was no call to action.
There was no thing that
says, this is why
this is worth reading.
So what you see here
is me saying I
really like this novel.
I really like this umbrella.
Doesn't say what you should do
when you read this. post.
So we have a feature we call
interactive posts.
And basically, what that
does is it adds a
call to action button.
So if I'm sharing this article,
I'm saying you should
click on it.
And when you land on their site,
you'd better listen to
the interview they did about
Salman Rushdie's book.
If you click on that, you
can buy the umbrella.
I strongly recommend
the umbrella.
It's kind of amazing.
The point about interactive
posts is that because they
have this very distinctive call
to action, for you as the
developer of the site, you have
a high clickthrough rate.
The important thing here is that
you have the button and
you have the link.
So when we're looking at an
interactive post, you can
pre-fill the text
in the comment.
So you can put your message.
Try not to make it something
the user will feel
uncomfortable with, because
the user can
just delete the comment.
You can +mention people in the
user's social graph, or rather
the subset of the user's
social graph
they've given you.
Again, if you abuse this,
they have control.
They can always delete the
people you're +mentioning.
But you can do some really nice,
clever things with this.
For example, you could +mention
people they know who
are very active in your site.
Or if you wanted to boost
re-engagement, you could
+mention people they know
who aren't very
active in your site.
Or if you're being especially
clever, you
could have a post--
in this case, about "Midnight's
Children," and
because you've merged the social
graphs, you could do
something like +mention a few
users who are very active that
a user knows and has given you
consent to know about and a
few users who aren't
very active.
And now the user has a post with
a conversation going on
with a mix of people who are
very engaged with your site
and people who are not very
engaged, and that will get
them to reengage.
So you've got the comment box.
You get the actual
content link.
If they user clicks on that,
they get to your website.
Then they have the button--
the call to action button.
They click on that.
We strongly encourage you to
have that be a distinctive
action so that when they click
on this button versus the
link, something different
happens.
So it might be I
click on this.
When I land on the web page,
music plays, because I already
said I want to listen
to the music or the
sound of the recording.
Or if I wanted to buy something,
I click on Buy.
When I land in their site,
the Buy flow begins.
The point is, you make it
distinctive, you make it
meaningful, you make
it valuable.
And because this is all based
on the same sharing
functionality we've always had,
it pulls in a snippet for
things like the title
and the image.
And of course, the user always
controls the audience, because
not everybody I know would find
Salman Rushdie's very,
very long book interesting.
And this way, I get to share
this with the right people.
And for you as a publisher,
having a user actively say,
this is something I wish you
people to listen to, I wish
you people to buy, is a much
more powerful endorsement than
you just writing it
for yourself.
So this kind of active sharing
tends to be seen as more
valuable by the users' friends
and people in their circles.
So implementing this
is very easy.
Like everything, you've got
to go to API Project.
You give a client ID.
You load our JavaScript, just
like with a button.
You choose a label out
of the 100 options.
You then design and
add your button.
The important thing is the
button you put on your site
can be different to the button
that's in the stream.
The button that should be on
your site should make sense
within the context of your site,
because you're trying to
get the user to click on that
button to begin the
interactive posting process.
And then the users in
the stream will
see a different button.
As you can see, it looks just
like the Sign-In button.
In fact, it inherits a lot of
functionality from the Sign-In
button, including things like
the class field that it's off.
So specify content URL.
This is where the user clicks
and goes through.
You get a deep link ID.
So does everybody know
about deep links?
Does anybody not know
OK, so the idea with a deep
link is that when somebody
clicks on the link, they get
to your website, and they
arrive at a particular page.
But wouldn't it be nice if they
could click on a link
that would take them to a
particular context within your
website or within your
application, so if it was a
mobile app?
So what this means is I can be
looking at a specific context
within a mobile app, share that
to the stream, and when
other people I know click
on that, we can
say, oh, this happened.
Maybe take it to the Play Store,
maybe take it to the
App Store, install the app, and
then launch the app, and
then send the app
that context ID.
And the app can say, oh, this
is happening, and then take
the new user to the same context
your original user was
looking at.
So we have the content URL.
It has its own deep link ID.
They don't have to match,
because it's up to your app to
interpret the deep link ID.
So it's a 512 character
identifier that's
up to you to control.
Client ID, cookie policy.
You can pre-fill the text.
Again, you want to make this
something the user's
comfortable keeping,
because otherwise,
they'll just delete it.
Pick your call to
action label.
You put the URL, it's going
to be behind the button.
And again, if you want
a deep link for that.
So this is effective because
it's a means for the user to
do active sharing to the
specific people they feel will
care about that.
And of course, if you want to
+mention people, there's a
data-recipients field
you can add as well.
Now, one of the interesting
things when you start out with
a small app, as I did seven
days ago with my demo
PhotoHunt is that initially,
there's nobody there.
There's just you.
And people say, hey, is Ade's
PhotoHunt a ghost town?
And you know, initially
a bit, it was.
And so what happened
was people turn up.
They'd hit the microphone and
say, is this thing on?
Is anybody here?
So how do you tell people?
How do you surface the
fact that there's
activity in your site?
How do you show the
world there's
something going on here?
So what we've designed to help
you, something we call app
activities.
The idea is that when something
significant happens
within your app for a signed-in
user, and you decide
what significant is, you write
what we call an app activity,
or a moment, to Google.
So you write this thing that
says, something interesting
happened on this URL,
and we store that.
And in the future, we'll find
interesting and relevant
places to surface that social
context to people the user
feels should have access.
I think this is the
important point.
When the user signed in, they
specified, you know what?
I'm on SoundCloud.
These are my music friends.
I'm OK for my musical friends
to know what I do on
SoundCloud.
And everybody else will
find it irrelevant.
That's OK.
So when these app activities get
written to Google, you can
see who has access to them.
You can see when they
were written.
You can see the snippet
that came with them.
You can see the service
that wrote them.
And of course, you can
always delete these.
So what is an app activity,
really?
Well, first thing is you have to
have an app activity type.
And we have 10 of them.
Now, I could read the list of
10 to you, but I won't.
But the point is, we have a
variety of different kinds of
raw activities, some of which
are very abstract, like Add or
Create, and some of which
are very specific,
like Listen or Review.
So this is saying, these are
something which they added
something to a collection, or
they created something, or
they reviewed something, or they
commented on something,
or they checked in
on something.
It's up to you, of course, to
decide what that something is.
So the something is the target
of the activity.
So this could be a URL.
And then on that URL, we'll look
in the page for microdata
describing the item type, where
they item type comes
from the schema.org ontology.
Or you can say the item
type, the name, the
description, the image.
If this sounds familiar, it's
because it's exactly what we
do with snippets in Search and
with snippets in the stream.
So it's exactly the same
technology we're using there,
with a couple of small
tweaks, though.
If you're designing this,
you've chosen your app
activity type.
You've gone through schema.org,
and you've said,
actually, my site has music
recordings, or my site has
music playlists, or my site has
creative works, or my site
has hospitals or whatever is
meaningful on your site.
And you've said this app
activity happened there.
It's important that the activity
you write are going
to be meaningful to the user,
because if and when we choose
to surface them, it'll be
something like, somebody you
know performed this activity
at this entity.
Or 50 people you
know did this.
Or 50,000 people listened to
this sound on SoundCloud.
So it's important you pick an
entity type that will be
meaningful to the user when they
see that social context
surface somewhere on Google, for
example, with our recent
search integration.
So when we think about app
activities, otherwise known as
moments, it's important to
understand that we have the
basic type, where you have an
activity or the target--
there's a URL of a page
somewhere out there.
And our user agent, or what we
call a snippet fetcher, will
make a request for that and
then look at the markup.
It's important to understand
that a snippet fetcher we use
for this and for snippets in the
stream is not Googlebot,
which means it has a documented
user agent.
And we're quite happy for you to
detect that user agent and
serve it just the microdata
it needs.
It makes debugging easier.
It makes a lot of stuff
much simpler.
But there are lots of
applications that
just don't have URLs.
Or they have a very
limited website.
Or they just have a website that
was never designed to be
parsed by a machine.
So we also have what we call
URL-less moments, where you
basically extract out the
item type, the name, the
description, the image, and you
put that in a JSON object,
and you write that to Google.
Of course, we also have an
optional start date field.
And again, what this does, it
lets you decide if you want to
write moments that are in the
past or perhaps in the future.
So for example, if I use a
site that lets me book
holidays, and it wants to write
that app package as
Google, well, the start
date isn't really the
data I booked it.
It might be the date
in the future
when I take the holiday.
Or if I'm using a social
location service that wants to
write my historical check-ins,
it would like all the
check-ins to have the
appropriate dates in
the past, not now.
So you can choose whether your
activities take place in the
past moment.
But by default, they are now.
So implementing this,
again, is very easy.
You've got your API project,
your client ID for this, your
Sign-in button, because if we
don't know who the user is,
then who did the app activity?
And you have to ask something we
call requestvisibleactions.
It basically is a scope that
says, I would like to write
these activities to Google.
That way, the user may say,
actually, I don't want people
finding out what I was listening
to on this site,
because it's embarrassing, or
because it's just not cool,
and people think I'm cool.
It's important that the moments
you're inserting are
meaningful.
So here's some examples.
So this is a really simple one
that's actually on our site.
So we maintain a URL
with an example of
a review of a widget.
And you can write and
add activity.
As you can see, it's a type,
a target, a URL.
It's very simple.
And then you just basically
write that as JSON to Google.
And of course, we also support
URL-less versions of this,
where all of the information
you would ordinarily have
specified is put into that
object and sent to us.
The important thing to also
notice here is there's an ID.
It's up to you to specify the
ID, because for us, it's an
infinitely long string
of-- set of blogs.
We don't know what they are.
How do we distinguish
them each other?
Well, it's up to you, because
you understand your data
better than we do.
So you specify an identifier
for it.
And here's both examples
in Java.
One of the reasons I like this
is that it's one of the few
places in the world where the
Java example is more concise
than in JavaScript.
So again, it's the standard
type, where you just specify,
here's the URL.
Here's the version where we
actually put all of the
information in there.
OK, you've got Sign-In.
You've got active sharing, where
the user is choosing to
do something to tell a specified
set of people.
You have app activities, which
give you sort of a passive
sharing, where as the user
does things that are
meaningful, you choose to
write those to Google.
And then Google chooses to
surface those to users when we
think it's relevant and
appropriate, rather than
becoming spammy.
So does all of this work?
How do you know?
Well, at Google, we think it's
really important that you act
on data rather than anecdotes.
So it's important that you
understand the impact of the
design changes you make.
It's important you have insight
into the integrations
you've done with Google.
So we have a feature we call
Platform Insights.
And it's a very simple idea.
We have all of this activity
going on on your site, which
because you have connected your
service to Google means
we can tell which users are
doing that, how many of them
are doing that, when
they're doing that.
So we surface that in a tab
on your Google+ page.
And that basically will
show you things like--
my demo app has been massively
successful.
I've had 90 users since
the 11th of May.
I think I'm about ready
to get some VC.
So I can tell how many people
have signed in.
But I can also do things like
see how many of them actually
made interactive posts, as well
as how many of them did
things that cause me to
write an app activity.
And of course, with the
interactive posts, I can see
what was the clickthrough
rate.
So doing this is fairly easy.
You create a Google+ page
for your service, which
is just very easy.
Here's mine.
It's not terribly pretty,
but it works.
You then go to your API Console,
and you put the
identifier for your page
in the API Console.
So in larger organizations, this
means the social media
people who run your page and the
developers have to meet.
You put that in, you hit Request
connection, and then
on your Google+ page, you get
a section here that will
basically say a project
requested a connection.
The simplest and easiest way of
seeing this work in large
companies is just to have the
social media people and the
developers come into a room,
flip their laptops open,
Request connection,
Yes, Accept, done.
You could try and do
it through email.
So now you can see that my
project number for my demo app
is 53211, et cetera.
And it's now connected to my
Google+ page, which means
everybody who has management to
my Google+ page can see the
data about the effectiveness of
the project, the web app.
So create a page, connect the
page in the API project, and
you've got Platform Insights.
The other thing, and the really
important thing, is not
just to say, oh, look how pretty
these pictures are.
It's to act upon them.
So if you look at this, for
example, you'll see that my
app only really had activity
on two days.
And that's in the two days
I posted and begged
people to use it.
So the action I would take from
this is, I should be able
to use this on a daily basis.
But the point is, you see this
data, you perform some action,
and then you see if
the data changes.
So you've got Sign-In,
you've got app
activities, you've got sharing.
How do you wrap all of
this up in a bow?
If there's one vision that's
underlines everything we're
doing at Google, it's this idea
that we can connect all
of Google's services together.
Because the user has multiple
Google services that they're
using, you can connect them
together and do something
interesting with that.
So for example, this
is a French
company called Jolicloud.
And they had this rather nice
idea that when you sign in to
their service, you can connect
your Google+, your Drive, your
YouTube, your Picasa.
But instead of deciding for you,
they ask the user, which
one of these do you connect?
The user clicks a bunch
of check boxes.
They dynamically construct
the scope string.
You click Sign in to Google,
and only the services you
chose to be asked about
were requested.
The beauty of this is that they
can use language that
makes sense to their users and
then use that to control the
scopes they request, rather than
making it a OAuth-level
decision for the user.
The point of all of this is
that with Sign-In, you can
basically connect to the users,
use unique Google+
social features, like the new
approach we have to hash tags,
communities, pages, and then
create a unique and social
experience that's valuable
for your users.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ADE OSHINEYE: So I think we
have time for questions.
Anybody have any questions?
While we're waiting for Tantek
to get up, I should just point
it out, you can go to
that short URL.
And in about 20 minutes' time,
it'll have all the links that
are relevant to this
presentation.
We have a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, this is
Tantek from Mozilla.
Quick question--
and I was trying to pay
attention to the APIs, but
maybe I just missed it, and
I checked it online.
Do you get a permalink back
to the mentioned post
on G+ on your site?
ADE OSHINEYE: So if you make a
post, and the user chooses to
share it through an interactive
post, you do not
get a permalink, because the
user may choose to share that
post to a set of people that
you don't have access to.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But if they do choose to
share it publicly--
ADE OSHINEYE: If they choose to
share it publicly, you can,
because you've connected to
their account, go through
their stream-- the public
stream-- and find
that post, as well.
Or use Search.
Basically, what we want to make
sure is that if the user
says, I trust you with my Music
circle, and then I see
something really funny, and I
share it with my Family circle
because my brother recorded
a song, you don't
have access to that.
AUDIENCE: That totally
makes sense.
I'm just thinking about the
public scenario, where they do
say, hey, I want to actually
post this publicly.
This is a great song,
or whatever.
ADE OSHINEYE: So even with
public, we don't treat that
differently.
You could still go and fetch
that if you wanted to, but
it's not something we do.
AUDIENCE: So you have
to use some sort of
heuristic to go find it?
Like, you can't be sure?
ADE OSHINEYE: Correct.
But if you've got a use
case, please tell us.
We'd be happy to look at it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I guess the use case would be so
that the user comes back to
your page, it's like, hey,
you shared this.
Do you want to go look
at your post again?
And you provide a link to it
rather asking them to share it
again and again and
again every time
they visit your page.
ADE OSHINEYE: OK, that
sounds cool.
AUDIENCE: So that's
the use case.
ADE OSHINEYE: Yes.
All right.
We should talk about
that afterwards.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Meg.
I'm with Fandango.
We just did an integration
with Google+.
ADE OSHINEYE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: We did one app
activity so far, which is when
someone watches a video or
trailer, for example, we're
writing that back to you.
ADE OSHINEYE: I've used that.
I watched the "Iron Man 3"
trailer on your site.
AUDIENCE: Oh, good.
So have I, multiple times now.
What I was wondering
about for that app
activity was we used Discover.
Are you going to publish
something that might be more
relevant, like Watch, in
terms of the verb?
I'm just wondering about--
ADE OSHINEYE: So right now,
we've got a limited set of 10
activities that we support.
If people come to us and say, we
have a compelling use case
for this, we would definitely
be interested.
And again, the Sandbox
is just downstairs.
Everybody in the platform team
is here, so come on down.
We'll get a whiteboard, and
we'll look at what we could
with Discover.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you have a concept of
disconnect that basically cuts
the application off from the
user's Google account.
Is there also a concept of
logout, or is that just token
expiration?
ADE OSHINEYE: So currently,
right now,
disconnect revokes the token.
We don't really have a concept
of logout that's public.
We have a new-ish feature
that's part of our
cross-device auth that lets
you set a flag to say the
user's logged out.
But it's not an explicit
logout.
But we're definitely
looking at that.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question about these
activities, or moments.
I mean, maybe you don't want to
talk about the competition.
But certainly, I think you
have to compare it to the
Facebook open graph actions.
So in which ways can these
activities surface--
you just said back there
surface on Google--
which would be the places in
the stream and the search?
ADE OSHINEYE: So right now, the
only way we surface these
activities is if it's one of the
six launch partners of our
Search integration, we
usually show the
activity on that site.
We show what the most
popular activity is.
But as time goes on, you could
imagine all sorts of places
across Google we could
surface that.
But of course, I'm not allowed
to preannounce features.
AUDIENCE: But basically,
it's like still the
beginning of this.
ADE OSHINEYE: Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you focused a lot
on connecting G+ to your
application.
Do you have any hints or
warnings about using G+
Sign-In as the primary sign-in
mechanism for your
application?
ADE OSHINEYE: So we'd be quite
happy for you to use G+
Sign-In as a primary
mechanism.
But what a lot of our partners
have done is they have a
post-registration step where
they say, hey, can you give us
your email address?
Or they ask for access to the
user's email address so they
can keep that so that if the
user disconnects, they can
reconnect later on.
There are other services, for
example, which after sign-in
force the user to create a
username and password.
We've had a lot of-- well, I've
had some emails to users
saying, why are they
doing this?
I've already signed in.
And we've also, at the same
time, had developers say to
us, I like doing that, because
it means if anything ever
happens to a user's Google+
account, they
can still sign in.
We've also had people say, well,
the nice thing about
multiple identity providers is
you can connect all of them to
the same underlying account
on your service.
And in fact, my colleague Ian
did a talk just here, just
before me, talking about
how you do that.
So unless there are any more
questions, I think that's the
end of this.
We'll be downstairs in
the Google+ Sandbox.
We also have this really
awesome GIF photobooth.
I recommend you try it.
It uses Google+ features,
and I built it, and
I really like it.
Otherwise, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]